welcome to the show, which almost didn't happen
today.
We were probably 10 minutes from having to
cancel today's show.
It is quite
a story and I'll tell it on the bonus show
today.
Uh, it's a good one.
There are two concepts that I've been talking
about which really are necessary concepts
to understand if we want to interpret it and
understand the Trump presidency.
And these two concepts are the Overton window
and creeping normality.
And these are two terms that will help to
shed light onto how we are all truly becoming
numb to different degrees, to Donald Trump's
lawlessness.
And there's a really good letter to the editor
in the La Times from over the weekend, which
said that much like a victim of abuse who
gets hit once and then twice and then 10 times
you start to become numb to that abuse.
And in the same way we all to some degree
have become numb to Donald Trump's lawlessness,
his ignoring of rules and regulations, his
being a scofflaw and most importantly his
suffering.
No consequences from it either.
And the letter to the editor in the La Times
very astutely points out many of the examples
of this, the abuses of power and the corruption
and the cronyism and the violations of the
Hatch Act.
But I understand what it is that's happening
here.
The outrage and the disarray that people are
experiencing as emotions over the Trump presidency
are logical emotions, but they are emotions
that consume a lot of human energy, of emotional
energy.
And at a certain point, most reasonable people
will sort of give in and move on because it's
just draining and exhausting to continually
experience those emotions.
And when you add to this a significantly radical
move of the Overton window to the right and
the creeping normality that we have experienced
over the last two and a half years, it's a
recipe for an authoritarian president who's
very actions have made the population numb
to his blatant disregard for what's right
and moral and sensible.
As a reminder, the Overton window is sort
of a range of what's acceptable for debate
in the public discourse.
Uh, what are the, if we talk about abortion
or we talking about taxation, what are the
sort of accepted boundaries on the left and
right of that debate and the right has significantly
benefited from pulling that over to the window
to the right, which moves the middle to the
right as well and creates more of an uphill
battle for the left to fight against.
Creeping.
Normality is another term where you can't
just jump to many of the debates we're having
today, they have to creep in as normal debates.
If Trump on day one ordered a strike on Iran
and then canceled it at the last second and
we found out that it was because he was told
that that last hack and how many people would
die, there would be much more outraged than
there was just two weeks ago when that very
thing happened because this new status quo
under Trump first had to become the baseline
status quo.
And it's really important to understand that
normalization doesn't mean people start to
think the things Trump is doing are okay.
What's Trump doing is fine, is not what creeping
normalization means.
It means that you sort of start white flagging
it and throwing your arms up in the air and
saying, this is all insane.
I've got no power over any of this stuff.
I'm going to go play a video game or watch
a Netflix show, which is in a sense, a sort
of logically adaptive behavior for the individual
health of individuals.
Although it's extremely unhealthy for our
society to allow this creeping normalization
of radical ideas to seep in.
Now, I want you, not to get me wrong, there
are many Trumpists who do genuinely think
everything that Trump is doing is okay.
I'm not talking to them in this segment, okay?
I'm talking to people with a good head on
their shoulders.
People who don't think that what's going on
is okay, but are experiencing that fatigue,
uh, that I've described before as well, which
is why I'm trying to take weekends totally
off from news and politics as I did over the
long a 4th of July break.
It's not that Trump, uh, as an example.
It's not that when, when Trump glorifies dictators
and criticized as our allies, we think it's
fine.
It's that we've become used to it.
And what can we really do about it anyway,
other than of course, vote him out in 2020,
which I hope we're all going to do.
So this is really dangerous.
It's going to take a really long time to repair
the damage that has been done.
And the removal of Trump from office in 2020
is merely step one of, I don't know how many
of many, many steps.
And the goal here is that we have to understand
that we have to some degree become numb and
we have to fight what is admittedly that natural
reaction if we can, because we don't want
that numbness to allow any level of indifference
of inaction when we can have an effect on
the society around us, on the country, around
us.
Uh, and this also relates to the very disturbing
recent trend of extreme right wing ideology
becoming mainstream, at least in some circles.
And that's exactly what I want to talk about
next.